okay let's see who is next today there
are so many people holding today let's
go to the nine five one area code who's
this from 951 sorry my mom this is
Blaire hey Blaire what's going on
oh that's going well David I have a
question for you that I wrote a long
time ago about a it's a climate change
question so I'll just read it off and
I'll take my question about there okay
so uh I said David given that you
believe that the socialist principle is
inherent inherently authoritarian which
I wholeheartedly agree with after all
the socialist principle states that each
according to his ability to each
according to his needs which I believe
is inherently authoritarian principle to
be the motivating factor within a
society because of the LeBron James
argument and if you want to explain that
to your of yours go ahead now with that
being said how can you reconcile being a
social democrat win a free market
capitalist society cannot stop the
threat of climate change that is surely
coming forth for all of us
perhaps the means of production will
have to be controlled by a global
government one day very soon so do you
think you are being unrealistic about
the threats that face us all the IPCC
estimate
Alissa's is conservative at best because
they exclude Arctic and Antarctic data
from their models and even the Trump
administration says that this planet
will warm by seven degrees Fahrenheit by
the end of the century if that happens
David people like you and I are going to
be caught up in the milk because we're
the old in the middle of this [ __ ] in
our goodies and sixties trying to
survive hoping for some science fiction
technology to save us this is this is a
lots of impact I'll take my answer out
there okay yeah I'm if you can just hold
on for one second the the problem with
the question is asked is that there's no
way to really just answer it because
it's sort of throwing together a whole
bunch of different things which are
sometimes only tangentially related
you're talking about in a way is
socialism the only way to actually deal
with climate change you're mixing in
there the different
you know you're sort of conflating
so-called free market capitalism with
well-regulated Nordic style capitalism
so I think that there's no way for me to
just kind of like answer the question
but I think it's been laid out pretty
extensively how well regulated Nordic
style capitalism what many of us know is
social democracy actually can deal with
the issue of climate change I also don't
believe it's been proven that socialism
would necessarily deal with it either so
I think we've got to kind of reset the
framing maybe a little bit okay I guess
he did hang up and really wanted me to
answer the question off air okay I think
the question is flawed at at it's sort
of core core level